nouveau temps que la première je vais me
laver très tôt madier très bien sentir
bon passons allez voter pour mon leader
et c'est mon devoir donc comme c'est un
devoir je vais m'acquitter de ça et puis
voilà les tranquillement oui j'ai
toujours voté nous devons choisir nos
députés
cette responsabilité il faut il faudra
suivre dimanche je dirais franchement
non c'est décourageant de voter quelques
de faire confiance à lui il vient et ça
complique et c'est plus compliqué quoi
s'est passé c'est décourageant ah je
vais voter je vais voter ça je serais le
premier au lieu le water parce que là il
faut un changement il faut un changement
avec ce système là je vais voter je vois
régulièrement depuis une vingtaine
d'années c'est vrai que l'assemblée
nationale c'est important le pouvoir
législatif bon je pense que quand même
c'est important parce que des
représentants du peuple j'ai ma carte je
vais voter
ou à lui c'est important pour moi ne
voit pas se mettre toujours devant la
télé où nous vendons portable dans les
réseaux sociaux en train de parler il
faut aller voter je compte ouvrir
dimanche contribuer au développement de
manger reste et surtout participer au
changement de ces bi d'image je vais
aller voter quoi je vais aller voter et
puis je souhaite que le meilleur gagne
sans aucune sans aucun problème
qu'il y ait la paix au sénégal
[Musique]